aujourd'hui on ne reçoit pas les deux
c'est le service minimum depuis trois
jours une grève pour exprimer une colère
et un ras-le-bol dues à un épuisement
des quarante et un manipulateur il y en
a six qui assure les nuits sur la
semaine samedi soir et dimanche soir
et ces manipulateurs peuvent desservir
l'ensemble de pzk c'est à dire le
nouveau plateau technique plus l'ancien
plateau technique plus les radios ou lis
plus les urgences plus les scanners en
urgence plus les irm en urgence s'ajoute
à ce problème celui des contractuels des
personnels précaires qui attendent pour
certains depuis des années une
titularisation ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est que le manque
d'effectif médical et non médical fait
que la base n'est pas assurée les
patients en moyenne attendre quelques
mois pour avoir un examen radiologique
sous des masses ou des pathologies qui
sont évolutifs comme le cancer on sait
qu'ils en martinique photos de cancer de
la prostate notamment donc de la base le
passé ans et déjà les ai donc laradj
aujourd'hui est un des piliers de
l'hôpital ici on veut relever l'hôpital
il faut commencer par la radio ce
service est il l'illustration d'un
paradoxe ouvert il ya un an et demi le
service est doté d'appareils ultra
performant permettant de mieux cibler la
pathologie irm fonctionnelle scanner
interventionnelle un concentré de
technologie de quelques millions d'euros
et en face un personnel en grande
souffrance qui réclame depuis des mois
des moyens humains là nous demandons un
effectif médical donc des médecins
radiologues
nous demandons une dizaine de
manipulateurs radio une dizaine de
brancardiers une dizaine de secrétaires
vu l'état de fonctionnement
votre déficit veulent et manque de
moyens comment est ce que c'est possible
on a eu des échanges avec la direction
est jusqu'à présent ces échanges n'ont
pas été fructueux donc aujourd'hui on
manifeste clairement leur mécontentement
et tout cela dans le but de pouvoir
soigner des patients sur le sol
martiniquais des investissements
technologiques majeures sans moyens
humains est ce possible
c'est tout le sens de cette grève
reconductible et illimitée